[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en que
hacemos un resumen de las noticias más
destacadas relacionadas con la pandemia
de kobe 19 en nuestro continente a
continuación algunos de los temas que
vamos a tratar en este programa
haremos énfasis en las secuelas que deja
la pandemia en la economía del
continente americano la inflación en los
problemas de desabastecimiento y los
altos precios del combustible así como
la guerra de rusia en ucrania dificultan
la recuperación de los países vamos a
analizar este tema con mi colega jorge
hurtado de la redacción de economía de
francia 24 en sintonía con este tema
económico también hablaremos de las
condiciones de desgaste en las que están
los sistemas de salud en general después
de dos años de la pandemia y también los
más recientes picos de contagio que se
han presentado y cómo se están
preparando para posibles repuntes
futuros porque la pandemia y la
emergencia sanitaria no han terminado y
con nuestros corresponsales daremos un
vistazo a la recuperación económica
después de estos dos años de pandemia en
méxico argentina y brasil son algunos de
los temas que tenemos para esta edición
comenzamos y ya como lo estaba diciendo
vamos a estar dedicados a hablar del
tema de la recuperación económica
precisamente porque la región de américa
latina y el caribe son unas de las más
golpeadas por la pandemia de kobe 19 la
repercusión se nota en el ámbito social
con el aumento en la pobreza y también
en la desigualdad según un estudio de la
cepal la región presenta los porcentajes
más altos de pobreza de los últimos 27
años veamos
la mayor crisis económica en américa
latina y el caribe desde 1950 así lo
denomina un estudio de la cepal esto
como consecuencia de la pandemia de kobe
19 en 2020 año en el que se registró el
primer caso de coronavirus en la región
el producto interno bruto cayó un 6,8
por ciento en américa latina y el caribe
y a pesar de que en 2021 el pib creció
un 5,9 por ciento 5 millones de personas
más en el continente entraron en pobreza
extrema en ese año alcanzando las 86
millones de personas en consecuencia las
principales monedas han perdido valor la
inflación ha alcanzado índices
históricos el trabajo informal ha
aumentado así como también la deuda
pública para las economías emergentes
de esta crisis hemos salido de la
pandemia más endeudados
más pobres más enojados o sea bueno la
tormenta perfecta entonces y la verdad
es que no vemos y con gran incertidumbre
hoy por hoy nadie tiene certeza de qué
va a pasar y por eso es tan importante
mirarnos de nuevo como región américa
latina' tuvo una recaída en sus bolsas
en 2021 y los capitales migraron a
refugios más sólidos como el dólar
estadounidense y algunos activos según
el banco mundial la región impulsó las
remesas globales en 2021 el país más
beneficiado fue méxico que acaparó el 42
por ciento de los 126 mil millones de
dólares que ingresaron a los países de
américa sin embargo la onu prevé que es
probable que la interrupción en la
educación y la reducción en personal en
diferentes empresas disminuirán los
ingresos futuros esto en la medida que
la unesco detectó una brecha en materia
de escritura en escolares
latinoamericanos los que más tiempo
tardaron en regresar a las clases
presenciales a nivel mundial la
desigualdad conspira conspira contra
todo y por lo tanto hay que abordarla
desde todas sus caras reestructurar el
sistema de salud y sobre todo la salud
primaria volver a la escuela los planes
de recuperación con inversión y la
igualdad de género el informe de la
cepal precisa que el 62 por ciento de la
población latinoamericana ya fue
inoculada con el esquema completo
mientras que en el caribe sólo el 34 3%
de los habitantes pueden decir lo mismo
cifras que evidencian las desigualdades
y asimetrías entre los países
desarrollados y en desarrollo y la
fragmentación regional en la compra de
vacunas algo que implica un riesgo de
nuevas variantes del virus
el kobe 19 aún no ha terminado
reconstruir mejor significa que todas
las personas en todas partes tengan
acceso a las vacunas no sólo es la
manera de no dejar a nadie atrás sino de
volver a encarrilar los objetivos de
desarrollo sostenible la pandemia ha
puesto en descubierto los déficits de
inversión pública de los sistemas de
salud de la región donde existe una
escasez relativa de recursos humanos
lado ms sugiere 35 médicos por cada
10.000 habitantes en la región sólo
cuenta con un promedio de 20 entretanto
la media de servicios interrumpidos por
el virus para los países de ingreso
medio bajo fue del 67 por ciento
mientras que entre los países de ingreso
alto dicha media se situó en el 34 por
ciento la opc indica que el control de
la crisis sanitaria es fundamental para
avanzar hacia una recuperación económica
sostenible
para profundizar en lo que ha ocurrido
en estos dos años de pandemia saludamos
hasta ahora al doctor carlos eduardo
pérez él es médico infectólogo y también
asesor científico de france24 doctor
pérez un gusto volverlo a saludar
gracias por acompañarnos aquí en el
programa y pago la precisión usted se
encuentra en colombia conoce muy bien el
sistema de salud de este país después de
dos años de pandemia cómo está el
sistema de salud colombiano está
desgastado el personal agotado cómo se
encuentra
santiago una de las cosas es que creo
que no es solamente en colombia
definitivamente el sistema de salud está
agotado porque fueron dos años de
intenso trabajo sobre todo en las áreas
de cuidado crítico pero además de es una
demanda de los demás un grupo de
pacientes de las más patologías nunca
bajaba entonces un doble esfuerzo y esa
gota recursos agota el personal hemos
visto situaciones de afectación de la
salud mental en personal de la salud de
burning de de ese tema miento pues
llamémoslo ha sido agotamiento por el
trabajo excesivo que ha hecho a muchas
personas pues retirarse de instituciones
de salud realmente estamos en una
situación donde se aguanta persiste pero
obviamente están lastimadas el
trabajador de la salud después de esta
pandemia doctor hablábamos de la
parálisis económica las fallas en la
cadena de abastecimiento esto claramente
también afectó a los sistemas de salud
en los diferentes países como hizo
colombia para sortear estas dificultades
cuando estaba también haciendo frente
precisamente a la crisis sanitaria y los
picos de la pandemia covile 19
y vamos a en colombia también hubo una
crisis sobre todo en medicamentos que
eran para pacientes críticamente
enfermos como relajantes musculares de
una digamos una falta de suministro que
fue suplida por la solidaridad de los
países yo creo que algo que encontramos
fue que hubo solidaridad y como la
epidemia no la pandemia nos afectó a
todos por igual habían países que tenían
menos casos y se pudo recoger de hay
algunos insumos sin embargo es una
situación que realmente es gasto y si se
vieron deficiencias en muchos de estos
elementos se sorteó de acuerdo a la
recursividad pero el gran problema del
déficit que tuvimos durante mucho tiempo
fue el ministro un asno que es un insumo
fundamental para poder dar un paso más
adelante en la pandemia y también los
sufrimos en la región doctor y en cuanto
a los recursos porque parte de los
recursos que había disponibles para la
salud se enfocaron netamente en combatir
la pandemia y se dejaron de lado otros
programas y quedaron pacientes
desatendidos en el caso colombiano cómo
hicieron para manejar esta situación
no estamos sufriendo esa situación
porque hay una gran cantidad de
enfermedades atendidas los pacientes no
se hicieron por ejemplo escriben para
cáncer las citologías vaginales no se
realizaron hubo mucha
diferencia en esos programas que venían
avanzados sobre todo en tamizaje
enfermedades no se realizaron porque se
concepto todo en la pandemia y hoy
estamos atendiendo un gran número de
pacientes con enfermedades desatendidas
y tratando de reparar pues ese atraso
que tuvimos en este en este tiempo el
santiago y estamos trabajando créeme que
el doble de lo que estamos trabajando
antes porque ahora tenemos que atender
no solamente las secuelas de ccoo sino
todo lo que dejamos de atender durante
ese tiempo de una forma eficiente el
reto sigue siendo muy grande para los
sistemas de salud doctor y así como
retrocedemos a nivel económico a nivel
social también a nivel técnico y a nivel
en los proyectos de desarrollo de los
sistemas de salud en el caso colombiano
que se dejó de hacer que quedó pendiente
en que se evidencia ese retroceso en el
sistema de salud colombiano
yo creo que hay cosas buenas que cosas
no tan buenas las cosas no tan buenas
probablemente están relacionados con lo
que mencionaba con el tamizaje por
ejemplo de enfermedades de cáncer o la
falta de estrategias de prevención la
disminución en la vacunación la
disminución de programas que se estaban
llevando en pacientes crónicos de clubes
de salud todo eso tú tienen que
replantearse hubo grandes avances en el
aumento de la capacidad hospitalaria el
aumento de capacidad en ventiladores el
aumento de la capacidad recurso humano
que se tecnificó mucho más y también
hubo una gran estrategia para poder
comunicar entre los hospitales y poder
hacer revisiones más eficientes
establecer niveles y también una
fortaleza en los sistemas de vacunación
porque ya vemos que la vacunación puede
llegar a cualquier lugar del país sin
disfrutar es es de bemoles esta
situación algunas no buenas algunas tan
buenas y de todas formas pienso que al
sobrevivir salimos fortalecidos con un
aprendizaje grande que somos trajiste un
aprendizaje de doctor precisamente esa
es mi última pregunta que lecciones
aprendidas en cuanto al manejo de una
pandemia porque la pandemia de kobe 19
sigue podemos estar enfrentando un pico
en cualquier momento que lecciones ya
hay aprendidas
creo que lo primero que estemos
aprendido es que los humanos somos
frágiles y que no hay ningún sistema de
salud perfecto que la solidaridad y las
ciencias son las que deben imperar en el
manejo de las grandes catástrofes y
tenemos que también hacer una reflexión
profunda sobre la asimetría social
porque vimos que el gran detonante son
las explosiones sociales que impidió por
ejemplo el control poblacional
creo que tenemos una
fortalecernos es muy probable que haya
unos brotes pero estos brotes van a ser
de menos intensidad por algunas sus
variantes y entre mejor inmunizados
estemos y sobre todo con refuerzos
posteriores con reformulaciones de las
vacunas pues vamos a tener menor impacto
sin embargo tenemos que estar siempre
alertas siempre solidarios cuidar
nuestra salud
málaga la higiene y tratar de sólo
fortalecer la ciencia vivimos que el
grande trazo de nuestra población fue
eso que no tenemos cómo hacer vacunas y
nosotros la verdad las ix el doctor pues
como siempre un gusto estar con ustedes
gracias por acompañarnos en esta
consulta aquí en kobe 19 la semana en
américa un gustazo
brevemente les presentamos otras
noticias destacadas de la semana en
nuestro continente comenzamos en canadá
este país norteamericano ya no exigirá
pruebas de kobe 19 o pcr para ingresar
al país si los viajeros están vacunados
con el esquema completo esta medida
busca agilizar la reactivación de la
industria turística de canadá para el
verano boreal brevemente también les
cuento que la ms avanza en la creación
de un pasaporte digital internacional de
vacunación con este certificado este
organismo internacional busca facilitar
los trámites requeridos para los viajes
internacionales y finalizamos con
noticias que da el alcalde de la ciudad
de nueva york que eximió a los
deportistas y a los artistas de el
requisito de vacunación una
obligatoriedad vigente en esa ciudad
estadounidense la decisión tiene lugar
después de varias semanas de peticiones
por parte del mundo del deporte que
impedía que el astro de los nets de
brooklyn kyrie irving disputará partidos
en la casa de su propio equipo
y ahora nos vamos a ir hasta mexico allí
se encuentra mario carbonell nuestro
corresponsal en la ciudad de mexico para
conocer detalles de cómo ha impactado la
pandemia kobe 19 en la economía mexicana
mario un gustazo saludarlo gracias por
acompañarnos en el programa y bueno dos
años de pandemia el impacto como se ha
visto reflejado en la economía mexicana
así es el golpe ha sido muy fuerte la
caída ha sido profunda incluso por
debajo del promedio de la ocde incluso
la organización para la cooperación y
desarrollo económicos ha señalado que en
el tercer trimestre de 2021 las familias
aún no recuperaban el nivel de ingresos
que tenían antes de la pandemia y el más
reciente reporte de la ocde refiere que
en el cuarto trimestre de 2021 méxico es
una de las dos naciones que red no
registró crecimiento de su producto
interno bruto esto luego de que alemania
incluso se contrajera
de esta magnitud ha sido el golpe en la
recuperación ahí va hay que decirlo es
el sector manufacturero y el de servicio
de los que van liderando esta
recuperación en materia de empleos bueno
se perdió un millón de empleos y estos
buenos de acuerdo con las autoridades se
han recuperado incluso febrero ha sido
el febrero con más alta cifra de
creación de empleos formales desde que
se tiene registro varios o en cuanto al
punto de vista económico pero después de
dos años de pandemia cómo está el
sistema de salud mexicano ha habido
varios picos de contagio también pues la
pandemia no ha terminado cómo se
encuentra el sistema de salud mexicana
efectivamente el sistema de salud bueno
se vio muy golpeado por la pandemia hubo
momentos en que la infraestructura
hospitalaria estaba a su máxima
capacidad a punto de desbordar y esto ha
traído la intención del gobierno de
reestructurar por completo el sistema de
salud de federalizar lo es decir que los
estados entreguen a la federación sus
servicios de salud para que ésta se haga
cargo y esto implicará de acuerdo con el
plan que tiene el gobierno de lópez
obrador una inversión equivalente a los
10 mil millones de dólares esto para que
todas las personas que no tengan
seguridad social puedan contar con
servicios de salud universal y gratuitos
en todo el país esa es la proyección que
se tiene
dada bueno la realidad que vino a
reflejarse a raíz de la pandemia
-mario y en materia económica que
pronosticó o que proyecciones hacen las
autoridades mexicanas en cuanto a la
economía son optimistas
los pronósticos de crecimiento no son
nada halagüeños incluso todos se
implican un recorte en el fondo
monetario internacional por ejemplo
ajustó su pronóstico a 2.8 por ciento la
organización para la cooperación y
desarrollo económicos a 2.3 por ciento
el propio banco de mexico el banco
central su expectativa para este año es
de 2.2 por ciento y si nos vamos más
allá en la conferencia de la 1 para el
comercio el desarrollo lo justo hasta el
1.3 por ciento en contraste el
presidente lópez obrador se dice
optimista y él asegura que el
crecimiento será este año de 5 por
ciento incluso la lanza el reto a los
especialistas dice aunque se enojen los
tecnócratas esto va a ser así y no sólo
este año sino que el pronostica un
crecimiento de 5 por ciento para 2023 y
para 2024 dice que si él no es optimista
entonces quien que son fórmulas las de
los expertos que les enseñaron en la
escuelas privadas así que él va a
demostrar que esto será diferente ya
veremos ya veremos
-mario muchas gracias por este completo
reporte completo panorama de la
situación económica en méxico debido a
la pandemia actualizamos ahora algunas
cifras veamos cómo está avanzando el
número de contagiados y de fallecidos
por cuenta del cob y 19 en la región de
centroamérica comenzamos en guatemala
allí registran más de 821 mil 800 casos
más de 17.200 personas han fallecido en
ese país en el salvador la cifra de
casos supera los 161 mil y la de los
fallecidos supera los 4 mil 100 mientras
tanto en costa rica los casos ya rondan
los 800 33 mil los fallecidos superan
los 8 mil 200 en honduras la cifra
supera los 420 mil casos y los
fallecidos ya superan los 10 mil 800
finalizamos en panamá en donde hay
oficialmente más de 762 mil 700 casos
reportados y más de 8 mil personas han
fallecido de nicaragua no podemos darle
cifras porque hasta el momento no hay
una actualización reciente por parte de
las autoridades nicaragüenses
un reporte del total de casos y de
fallecidos recientes allí debido al cob
y 19
m
bueno vamos a analizar entonces el
impacto que ha tenido estos dos años de
pandemia la economía en la región de
américa latina nuestro tema central del
programa para eso hemos invitado al
estudio a jorge hurtado de la redacción
de economía de france 24 hola jorge un
gusto tenerlo en el programa y quién
mejor para explicarnos aquí en detalle
lo que está sucediendo en la economía de
nuestros países y a ver comencemos
porque hay varios puntos para analizar
en cuanto a lo que hemos visto cómo se
ha ido afectando la economía debido a la
pandemia comencemos entonces por
analizar el impacto en el mercado
laboral de los diferentes países de la
región así es y bueno aunque muchos
recordarán que en 2021 varias economías
de latinoamérica y del mundo comenzaron
a decir que habían crecido
significativamente esto no se trata más
que un efecto rebote que en economía se
conoce cuando hubo una contracción
bastante grande que fue lo que sucedió
en 2020 por la pandemia pues
naturalmente esas economías también
crecieron significativamente pero no es
un crecimiento
natural sino más bien se trata de este
efecto económico que se conoce como
efecto rebote y esto no fue suficiente
este efecto positivo entre comillas para
la economía para que se recuperará el
mercado laboral porque bueno la pandemia
ocasionó el cierre de casi 3 millones de
empresas en américa latina' según datos
de la organización internacional del
trabajo de la oit esta crisis en el
mercado laboral de la región se podría
prolongar inclusive hasta el 2023 y el
2024 de los mate 49 millones de puestos
de trabajo que se perdieron en 2020 por
la pandemia aún hace falta por recuperar
45 millones a enero de este año las
cifras indican que hay aproximadamente
22 millones de más de 20 millones de
personas que en la región están buscando
empleo sin encontrarlo y un dato todavía
más alarmante en torno al dato del
mercado laboral es que estos empleos que
se han venido recuperando poco a poco
después de dos años de pandemia han sido
igual o similar a 2019 cuando uno de
cada dos trabajadores en la región
pertenecían al sector informal y como se
relaciona esto con por ejemplo el
sistema sanitario el sistema de salud
estas personas al encontrarse en el
mercado laboral evidentemente pues no
pueden acceder o se representan una
carga para el sistema público de salud
claro y lo peor es que la pandemia no ha
terminado entonces no sabemos hasta
cuándo va a extenderse esta emergencia y
estas cifras económicas podrían
alterarse con el paso de los meses
hablemos de la inflación que parece que
es un mal transversal no solamente para
los países de américa latina sino es
algo común en este momento para los
países alrededor del mundo cómo se cuela
precisamente de estos dos años de
pandemia así es los datos oficiales
indican que la inflación generalizada en
américa latina' ronda el 7,2 por ciento
y hay países que evidentemente se ven
más afectados sobre todo las economías
más grandes como colombia méxico chile y
argentina hay países que también tienen
algún tipo de inflación que se conoce
como inflación crónica estos son sur y
nada en argentina o venezuela que ya
padecían esto antes inclusive de la
pandemia pero la pandemia vino a agravar
esta situación que es el alza de los
precios la inflación en brasil
pues ronda ahora mismo más del 10 por
ciento es la más alta en 7 años en
méxico 7 29 por ciento y colombia la
sexta inflación anual es más grande o
más altas de américa latina' hablemos
ahora de la cadena de suministros y los
altos costos que tienen los fletes que
eso también ha provocado problemas en el
desabasto problemas en el abastecimiento
ha llevado a un desabastecimiento de
supermercados farmacias y otro tipo de
productos así hemos ayudado muchísimo a
hablar de esto de los bloqueos en la
cadena de suministro básicamente
represento de que cuando ocurrió la
pandemia muchas empresas comenzaron a
cerrar por las restricciones del comit
19 esto obligó evidentemente a muchas
empresas también a despedir trabajadores
al reabrirse las economías del mundo
comenzaron a hacer los pedidos de forma
masiva y las empresas e inclusive el
transporte marítimo no tuvo cómo
responder a esta demanda tan grande el
costo del flete se disparó al doble de
lo que era en 2020 inclusive y según la
organización de naciones unidas estima
que el aumento del costo de los fletes
de continuar estos problema cadena de
suministros que ahora se agravan con la
guerra en ucrania pues los costos
podrían aumentar en un 11% y esos costos
se van al consumidor hablemos ahora de
las protecciones que hay para la región
para los diferentes países qué tan
optimistas son las cifras de las
autoridades en américa latina' ahora
recientemente esas cifras se han tenido
que reevaluar sobre todo por la guerra
en ucrania según la cepal américa latina
va a desacelerar su crecimiento al 2,1
por ciento también en las naciones
unidas para el comercio y el desarrollo
dijo ayer que la región va a crecer
solamente 2,3 por ciento influido
específicamente por la guerra en ucrania
y en países como áfrica del norte por
ejemplo
y medio oriente ya se han dado algunas
manifestaciones que este escenario se
podría replicar en los países de américa
latina porque el costo de la vida pues
sigue en aumento y lo seguirá empiezan a
mezclarse temas la pandemia con la
guerra de rusia en ucrania y empiezan a
mezclarse de los temas y el panorama no
mejora jorge muchas gracias por este
completo análisis económico de nuestra
región muchas gracias por habernos
acompañado hoy en el programa vamos a
hablar ahora de nación en estos
programas continúan en la mayoría de los
países veamos cómo están las cifras para
el cierre de esta semana veamos el
porcentaje de población que tiene el
esquema de vacunación completo
comenzamos de norte azul comienzo en
colombia allí el 67 21 por ciento de la
población ya tiene la vacunación
completa en ecuador el 76 54 por ciento
un poco más al sur en perú el 75 90 por
ciento de la población ya tiene un
esquema completo la vecina bolivia
alcanza el 48 58 por ciento y vamos a
finalizar en chile en donde el
90,29 por ciento de la población ya está
vacunada chile siempre ha sido uno de
los países líderes no solamente en la
región sino también a nivel mundial
y ahora veamos cómo está la situación en
argentina un país que entró a esta
crisis sanitaria de la pandemia de kobe
19 estando ya arrastrando serios
problemas económicos natalio cause hoy
en buenos aires nos va a dar más
detalles hola natalio gracias por
acompañarnos hoy en el programa y la
pregunta de partida dos años de pandemia
kobe 19 como se ha visto esto reflejado
en los indicadores económicos de la
argentina- entinas ya estaba en una
situación económica crítica con alta
inflación y pobreza datos que todavía no
mejoran a eso además se sumó la caída
del empleo y de la actividad económica
aún con ayudas directas del estado a las
familias ya las empresas la pobreza
saltó del 35 a más del 40 por ciento de
la población y en 2020 la economía
retrocedió un 10 por ciento aunque ese
10% se recuperó durante
también en 2020 aumentó el desempleo
aunque otra vez en 2021 cayó y terminó
alrededor del 7% de todos modos esta
recuperación del empleo
ha sido igual para los trabajadores
formales que para los informales y
incluso para las mujeres y también para
los más jóvenes sobre todo el trabajo
informal vio una recuperación mucho más
baja de los salarios que el trabajo
formal todo esto además en un contexto
de una inflación que no baja del 50%
natalio importante conocer en qué
condiciones se encuentra en este momento
el sistema de salud argentino y qué
proyecciones de crecimiento hacen las
autoridades para la economía del país
para los próximos meses
el sistema de salud de argentina no
llegó a verse desbordado eso es muy
importante y tiene que ver con que un
gran esfuerzo para nutrir el sistema de
insumos y de recursos y también de
equipos y aunque hubo algunas demoras en
un primer momento hubo una provisión
adecuada de vacunas y una inmunización
adecuada de la población argentina
durante la pandemia eso sí se redujo la
atención de otras necesidades de salud
calle cayó el diagnóstico de muchas
enfermedades y se postergaron
intervenciones algo que se ha ido
recuperando en los últimos meses tal vez
el impacto más fuerte fue ha sido sobre
los trabajadores de la salud que fueron
los que más se agotaron y sufrieron por
el esfuerzo realizado durante la
pandemia y es algo que además reavivó en
el país el reclamo por mejoras
salariales y laborales en el sector
salud
natalio muchas gracias por este reporte
desde la ciudad de buenos aires en
argentina y ahora demos un vistazo a
otras noticias relacionadas con la
pandemia que fueron destacadas también
en las redes sociales comenzamos con
noticias de la organización de las
naciones unidas- que titula la pandemia
de kobe 19 sigue activa los casos suben
de nuevo y la alerta sobre brotes
locales después de varias semanas de
descensos los casos de kobe 19 vuelven a
subir globalmente a una tasa del 8% lado
ms por ejemplo insistió en que esto
puede ser el preludio de un nuevo pico
de casos y también de un problema mucho
mayor
ecuador eliminar restricciones de aforo
por kobe 19 debido a la buena tasa de
vacunación cercana a los 48 millones de
personas con el esquema completo esto
llevó a que el presidente ecuatoriano
guillermo lazo retirara las
restricciones de aforo que fueron
impuestas hace dos años eso sí la
mascarilla va a seguir siendo exigida en
todo tipo de ámbito tanto público como
privado y en las calles o en el interior
de las viviendas y vamos a venezuela
nicolás maduro anunció la normalización
de las clases en los niveles o en todos
los niveles a nivel nacional la
normalización comenzará a partir de la
próxima semana tanto en escuelas liceos
como en universidades las clases
presenciales en venezuela fueron
suspendidas hace 19 meses debido a los
casos de covite 19
y para terminar esta ronda nos vamos a
ir hasta brasil es la economía más
grande de la región pero que también ha
hecho cara a dificultades para poder
hacer frente a la pandemia de kobe 19
vamos entonces hasta río de janeiro allí
se encuentra valeria saccone para
profundizar en este tema hola valeria un
gusto saludarla de nuevo allí en la
ciudad de río de janeiro y bueno la
pregunta base dos años de pandemia como
se han visto reflejados en los
indicadores económicos de brasil
el problema de la economía en ese
momento en brasil es la inflación el año
pasado la gasolina subió 13 veces y eso
se repercute en toda la economía porque
el 60 por ciento de las mercancías en
este país son transportadas por
carretera
si miramos los datos macroeconómicos
vemos que el año pasado se cerró con una
subida espectacular del pib
4,6 por ciento tras el desplome del 39 %
de 2020 el primer año de pandemia es el
mejor resultado desde 2010 cuando el pib
de brasil creció un 7,5 por ciento los
dos sectores que han arrastrado el pib
para arriba han sido la industria y los
servicios especialmente todo lo que está
relacionado con el comercio electrónico
es decir almacenaje y envío de
mercancías sin embargo hay que decir que
hay un dato muy significativo que es la
vacunación del 81% de la población de
brasil está permitido la reapertura de
todo y la reactivación de la economía
aún así unicef pide cuidado porque el
riesgo de que la pobreza monetaria de
los niños y de los adolescentes aumente
es muy grande y puede duplicar la
pobreza de los adultos
valeri puntualmente el sistema de salud
brasileño cómo se encuentra después de
estos dos años de pandemia y qué
proyecciones económicas en las
autoridades allí en brasilia
el suceso sistema único de salud de
brasil es el sistema sanitario público
más grande del mundo y atiende a una
población potencial de 212 millones de
personas creado en 1990 en poco más de
30 años de existencia siempre tuvo que
lidiar con una falta crónica de recursos
eso quedó patente al principio de la
pandemia cuando faltaban insumos básicos
como mascarillas y guantes aún así ha
reaccionado bien a la presión sanitaria
en un país donde ha habido más de 30
millones de casos confirmados de kobe de
esos y este año ha tenido un recorte del
20 por ciento de su presupuesto con lo
cual la va a tener que hacer más con
menos dinero y también la recuperación
económica según muchos economistas este
año está en entredicho tras el buen
desempeño del pib del año pasado que
ligaron al desplome de 2020 para este
año la proyección es mucho más contenida
para algunos va a ser de una subida del
0,3 por ciento y para otros economistas
puede llegar como mucho a un por ciento
de crecimiento del pib
valeri a muchas gracias por este reporte
desde rio de janeiro y así llegamos al
final del programa nos vemos la próxima
semana aquí en kobe 19 la semana en
américa sigan viendo france24 hasta
entonces
[Música]